[Music]
all right so
the country is now gearing up for
presidential elections
yeah in november everyone can't wait
right that's why the country is
in shambles why is it all just mailboats
the [ __ ] are you drunk no i'm trying to
be like
hip-hop oh that was really that that
really connected with the youth
yeah so why a drunk man why is it why is
it only
usps mail votes and not
online votes it depends on their online
votes oh no they're people are going in
person too right yeah
they're both open if it depends on the
state yo
word can you go in person depends on
where you live bro why is it male
and not weapons are you guys appealing
to the the youth of the 80s
this is what they love they
they can't wait they can't wait to vote
for us that's right i'm hip with the
cool
and i say no to drugs
take a bite out of crime this is your
brain this is your brain
on drugs i don't like your hair
with the prince delicious
all right so yes as we are gearing up
for presidential elections there's a lot
talk of like uh what kind of voters are
going to be voting for
biden what kind of voters can be voting
for trump and i was curious being
asian-american in our company being
predominantly
american here what are the asian
american voters doing
this year and depends on where they live
oh true true because
and it depends on what kind of asians if
they're older vietnamese they're voting
republican
yeah if they're yeah or if they're uh
they just escaped communism
yeah most uh southern vietnamese
uh older people that are refugees or
they came from vietnam
they vote they lean more right they're
more republican
true you're not wrong because i haven't
grasped that
oh don't even show me let me guess more
okay okay okay okay all right here we go
you said you said vietnamese uh trump or
biden
trump correct ding ding ding filipino
trump or biden ah that's questionable
because
age group older guys probably trump
younger
democrat who likes to sing if i haven't
choose one
majority if i had to choose one democrat
dang correct correct asian asian what is
asian asian american asian american
asian american biden biden
i have to say the amount of don't knows
there is 23
yes chinese people actually rank the
highest and
i don't know i don't know man i don't
care
oh it's because you know why um i only
care about
i think we have to divide up the chinese
to mainland chinese new immigrants and
we have to
think about chinese that's been here
since the gold rush days
like the the canton there's a huge
chinese community
the chinese the yeah the chinese
community in
arizona that um
they have a big republican following and
that's why i thought
trump but there's also a lot of chinese
americans on the west coast
who are more left so yeah question
but i got them all right except for that
one true is there more yeah korean
oh oh there are three more three more
korean biden
yes japanese biden yes asian and indian
asian indian oh asian indian oh wow i
don't know that's a
i'm assuming biden very biting that was
they ranked the highest sixty-five
percent
oh we got chinese wrong [ __ ] that's
that's not that good though
can i ask my question very bad yes
what's your question uh
so so for every ethnicity is
they are american like citizens or
i think it's like immigrants like all
these were immigrants
and then asia like they have a category
for asian no these are all just the
american
those are those are what they are saying
yeah
thinking about the upcoming november
election for president of the election
why does it say
asian americans yeah asian american
advancing justice
like uh organization right yeah so why
do i have one just for asian america
yeah they can do oh it's all these mixed
together it could be the average of all
of them
that makes sense that makes sense well
asian indian american is what
that's the just in general asian
americans are like yo
because you have to be a citizen to vote
so everyone's a citizen you're right
yeah yeah everyone's a citizen but then
new so
or why would we retire your question
might be think about that but your
question might be
new immigrant versus like that's kind of
how many generations have you been in
america
that was that's what i was trying to get
up and my actual question is answered by
that
gotcha yeah but yeah so it seems like
asian
americans are predominantly democratic
this year
and uh that is actually a
interest this is an interesting take
here because i have a graph from 2016
and [ __ ] asians
so there's more conservative yes so
there is
actually a slight shift towards uh
republicanism trump's gonna [ __ ] win
you think so i do think so because that
kind of shift is crazy that's four years
that's four years yeah so this is this
is 2016. you know where the democrats
[ __ ] up the hardest
not putting gang on there because all
the asians i love
gang i love yang but you know what they
[ __ ] up is in 2016 they said
if you give him the nuclear code it's
going to blow up the whole world and he
all he had to do is not blow up the
world
how crazy is that they're so stupid
doing that [ __ ] it's so easy
yeah it's the easiest [ __ ] test you
could pass that's fine they
man the the party's like killing
themselves right now yes
especially well with all the controversy
like they snubbed bernie
you know with the first election twice
and then people were just like hold up
like
hillary stole that one right and then
they did it again
and then they just right in front of our
faces you know nobody wanted [ __ ]
biting no way
everybody else wanted birdie or like or
even as the number two if you're gonna
okay
we all know maybe biden could be dead in
the next couple years who knows because
he
he just doesn't seem to be all there
yeah why get kamala harris give
give bernie the slot but they didn't
obviously and he's
obviously the more popular and by far do
we know why
bernie was just snubbed like that i
don't think he's an establishment
candidate so here's the thing i think
the democrat
okay so corporatists right they
only have control through the old guard
politicians
and obviously in the republican party if
there
is a standing president they're not
gonna
take them down and replace them with
another republican they're going to keep
them in there so
it's kind of like for the next four
years they're kind of [ __ ] with
trump in that position like replacing
bush with chaining so like corporatists
are like he's not playing ball with us
so in our the only fighting chance we
have to restoring order the way that we
see fit
is throwing biden up there who will play
ball because
he he's been in office and he has the
highest chance
because he's think they're they're also
thinking about okay
so who's most likely to win
the votes of people who wanted like
how it was during the obama generation
well let's give them a piece of the
obama
administration which is biden and to
them it's like a good memory of how
things used to be
right so they're like he's the candidate
that will play ball
he knows the game and then so let's put
him in that wall street loves him
right the credit card companies love him
delaware loves him barclays loves him
big time so so so i think in that sense
it makes sense
where uh bernie is a wild card
bernie's anti-establishment he'll come
into the game he doesn't want corporate
money
he doesn't want pac money he really
wants to change america
he's not corrupt enough he can't be
corrupted so that's why
hillary will play ball biden will play
ball all these people will play ball
and then so they're like let's make it
work so then our cap will win so the
most ironic thing though is that they
said
okay well biden was gonna be the nominee
and then to bring the bernie people to
the fold they said you know what we're
gonna let you
help us with the party platform and then
the first thing the bernie people
brought in from the bernie campaign they
said we don't want corporate money
and the biden people are like [ __ ] you
that was the first thing that got
stricken down
well weren't they supposed to
collaborate they were supposed to but
then after that the game was said it was
like well we'll just we'll just
like say we're for the green new deal
and we won't implement anything it's all
good
so for for the democrats then they would
rather
uh say say biden doesn't win
they you think they would rather see
trump be re-elected
i think that the media would stand to
see sanders
have been a potential president yes
because the media knows that
bernie is anti-establishment and trump
will at least generate clicks as [ __ ]
for them and for their their advertisers
if you think the media doesn't want
trump to win you're not paying attention
the media wants trump to win like they
can't wait for all those clicks
trump has saved so many newspapers from
[ __ ] going out of business
he made politics kind of like worth like
listening and watching
it juicy want to tune in and watch
zucker was literally sending trump
debate prep
in 2016 google it like jeff zucker by
the way is the ceo of cnn
so this isn't exactly like like uh
new [ __ ] this is old [ __ ] but but
there's a reason why
cnn and all those guys msnbc they were
all pushing trump hard
am i wrong i don't know anybody calls
him fake news
sucker jeff zucker um um trump debate
prep 2016. while he calls him fake news
exactly
it's a game it is a big [ __ ] game
drama is yeah
it's it's fun if you see it that way
but they're also playing with people's
lives and that's what people feel sorry
that's why people feel sad about it
throw off a debate
yeah it's like i don't wanna be part of
your [ __ ] game go go there's an audio
call you can listen
that doesn't affect me yeah go go over
there
well i mean what what was it about
really oh yeah
but the the tweet thing like how he they
actually wrote like
plus percentages of like how much more
they have changed from 2016 to 2012 oh
yeah the other photo i gave you oh yeah
here we go
what is this tiff you found this photo
for me that says trump's gains with
asian americans according to api
and naas from 2016. oh here we go
numbers
so vietnamese gained 15 15 more in the
republican realm
yeah indians plus 12 koreans so everyone
went up
except for chinese they went down 15. i
think i think it was all the
the the chronovirus stuff maybe for
chinese true oh yeah
yeah i feel like um out of all the
asians though
if you're vietnamese and you support
biden
that is really [ __ ] up because biden
didn't support the the vietnamese
refugees
being rescued in america he was opposed
of that policy he was a he he was he
campaigned against it
he didn't want vietnamese people to come
here and seek refuge he was like
let's keep him in vietnam that's their
problem um
and it's recorded and it's out there too
and on top of that he didn't want
mixed integrated schools and all that
stuff that's part and to me i'm like
it's not about right or left it's about
liars
and even bigger liars and it's like he's
no
friend to minorities you know what what
i think
um because all that stuff was like way
back when right when biden was
making those comments decades ago
and um something that you can at least
i've never seen politicians do is own up
to their [ __ ] and be like yeah
that's how i felt before but this is how
i actually feel now like you never
really see any
genuine true friends yeah because people
change
and he could have been like yo i was
wrong but doesn't that show a sign of
like
flip-floppy and kind of weakness because
it's all like perception right
like i agree it would make them human
and more vulnerable and
now you have this connection but i think
if you um i don't know i feel like
people can really twist that manipulated
into being something
that's very weak like do you want your
president to like make these types of
mistakes with your life
and that's the sad part about like this
whole debate thing you know like in
debate they have uh
like names for tactics i'm just making
this stuff but i'll be like oh but he's
busting a susan b anthony right now
you know it's like they're it's like
they're they're they're having like
special
tactics for what they're doing so
they're almost playing the game of
debates
rather than actually like having a
strong argument or building
this is who i am i [ __ ] up so instead
of being real they're just playing like
the
technicality of the game yeah because
just recently because i
i don't really touch this whole politics
stuff but casey was showing me this one
debate
with who was it totally uh tulsi gabbard
versus uh
she has the most guilty face i've ever
seen
telling her like well when you were a
prosecutor like look at your numbers
like you put all these people in jail
and like that affected the community
like
what do you have to say about that and
she was just like well you know my
entire career i actually did
a lot of great things but not actually
the thing that she's talking about what
about the guy
that you didn't care about putting him
away for that's what she was talking
about and by the way did you see the
veteran who went against biden recently
who's like yo joe biden uh i have family
members who died
going to the war i went to these stupid
[ __ ] wars that you voted for and then
joe biden's like you know my son
he served and joe biden's son by the way
he served like 2008 he died
of cancer when he was well out of the
military in like 2013
years later but but nobody [ __ ] can
put those two things together especially
in our media thanks for that guys
so he's basically saying my son died
in that war but he didn't and so that's
the [ __ ]
that they're able to conflate those two
things to make political
hay yeah well yeah so uh
get out there and vote guys
[Music]